SAAD ALI: Hello, everyone.
I'm here a KubeCon Seattle.
And with me, I have
Dustin Kirkland,
Product Manager at Google
Cloud Kubernetes Engine.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: That's right.
SAAD ALI: Dustin, you have
been with Google and Kubernetes
for a while.
And we started with
the Google Cloud.
The Kubernetes engine has
taken off in the cloud.
Since then, what have
we've been working on?
What's new with Google Cloud?
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Yeah, I've
been really excited to work
on bringing GKE On-Prem--
so Google's Kubernetes
Engine, which
we host a software, as a
service version of Kubernetes,
in Google Cloud.
Back in August of this year,
Google announced our intention
to bring GKE on-prem.
SAAD ALI: And this is
completely new for Google.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: This is
new for Google-- yeah.
We've never really
taken Google technology
and put it into a data
center at this kind of scale.
From the background
that I have--
I have been working
with enterprises
and bringing Linux and open
source into those enterprises.
And so it's been fun
and interesting to share
what I've learned over a
20-year career doing that.
But here with Google, which has
some incredible technology that
typically is hosted
technology-- but doing
that on-prem in the
enterprise data center
is a different challenge.
SAAD ALI: And why now?
Why is Google
going into on-prem,
if this is not something
Google has done in the past?
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
Yeah, it's response
to an incredible
market opportunity.
There's a ton of workloads that
run much better in the cloud.
And I think we've seen the
explosion of public clouds
in response to that.
But increasingly, there are
workloads that cannot run
in the cloud, workloads
that have to run on-prem.
And that is a little
counter-intuitive
to, maybe, some people
who are 100% cloud native.
And so you think about something
like the retail industry
and the software that needs
to run inside of a store.
There are physical
sensors inside
of the store that
needs to have software
running against those sensors.
Now, those sensors can
feed data to the cloud,
where decisions can be made.
But the actual code that reads
the mag strip on a credit card
or the NFC or the chip
on a credit card--
that's code that has to run--
SAAD ALI: It needs to
be physically present--
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Yeah--
SAAD ALI: --in the store.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: --within a
couple of feet of the card
reader-- the chip reader.
The same goes for the sensors
inside of a restaurant,
inside of the
refrigerator or the store.
All that's internet
connected nowadays.
And I think, over the
next couple of years,
you'll see the
in-store experience--
the experience we have,
as a customer coming
into a brick-and-mortar
traditional retailer--
we're really going to see
that enhanced and enhanced
by technology in the store.
And across the board, every
retailer that I've met is
packaging their
own applications--
either applications they've
written or applications they
purchase from a third-party--
packaging those as containers
and deploying them to
thousands of stores--
multi-node clusters in
thousands of stores.
SAAD ALI: That sounds awesome.
So what are some of
the benefits that folks
are going to get when
they have their clusters
managed by GKE On-Prem?
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Folks
being your IT administrator?
SAAD ALI: Or retail
companies or whoever
is going to be
using GKE On-Prem.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right,
right-- so from a system
administrator--
an IT standpoint,
I think what you'll see
is Kubernetes managed
as appliances-- really,
appliances in the store,
where below the layer
of your application--
all of that's managed
as a service--
software as a service.
It's remotely updated.
It's remotely scaled, remotely
monitored, and remotely logged.
And the applications that
sit on top are scaled--
are deployed-- are run in
a very seamless manner.
SAAD ALI: That sounds awesome.
So when are customers actually
going to get access to this?
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Ha ha!
Good question-- 2019.
2019 is the year of
retail really adopting
incredible software at scale.
And I think it will change our
lives in ways that we're only
just beginning to see.
SAAD ALI: That's awesome.
And so moving forward, with
GKE going on-prem and all
of these things, is
Google going to continue
to invest in open source?
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Oh, absolutely.
I think it's in our DNA.
I've certainly been around
the open source industry
as a contributor and
author of open source
projects for decades.
It attracted me in
my journey to Google.
I've been with Google
for almost a year now.
Google's commitment
to open source
is something that I'm
very proud of and--
I think-- increases,
in fact, over time.
SAAD ALI: What are the
benefits of being open source?
Why continue that investment?
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Yeah-- I
think it's standardizing
on a common platform.
There are certain
aspects of software
that, once commoditized,
make for a better playing
field for everyone.
The differentiation
on certain things
that just don't benefit the
end-user for differentiation--
it really doesn't make sense.
And having a common
open source space
for that layer of the
infrastructure-- and that layer
started very low and
has slowly crept up--
crept up in a good way,
because I think we've layered
on better and better services.
The further to the top
of that stack you go,
the more commercialized or
productized and, in some cases,
proprietary that that is.
I think it's inevitable,
though, that the layers continue
creeping upward.
And I think that's a good
thing for us as open source
technologists and for
the end-users benefiting
from the technology.
SAAD ALI: Yeah.
What do you think about--
you have different
companies that are all
contributing to open source.
Sometimes, these companies
are seen as competitors
to a certain extent.
But open source is a place
where they actually collaborate.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Yeah.
SAAD ALI: What are
your thoughts on that?
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: It's the
nature of the game, in fact.
I think some of
the athletes that I
have the most respect
for are the ones who
have personal interpersonal
relationships with one another
off the field.
On the field, it's grid iron.
It's a battle.
But to shake hands at the
end of the game and say,
we were bested this time and
we'll do better next time--
that sort of collaboration, I
think, you see in open source
as well.
We will compete.
We will compete in the
market and from a technology
perspective.
But we'll also collaborate
around the open source.
And I think that's a sign
of good healthy companies
and good healthy
business models.
And on the flip
side, I think, when
you see organizations that
can't collaborate well,
that's a sign of something
unhealthy going on, perhaps,
in a business model.
SAAD ALI: Makes sense.
And looking forward into
2019, what are the things
that you're most excited about?
GKE On-Prem, of
course, but what else?
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
Yeah, so I'm going
to double down on that one.
I think, GKE On-Prem
at tremendous scale
in the Enterprise
Data Center for sure--
that's where we're
currently engaged today--
so putting GKE On-Prem
into racks of servers
in a traditional data center.
The other places at the edge,
in this retail sense-- thousands
of little data centers,
thousands of 5-node data
centers, right?
That is happening in 2019.
And I'm excited to
be a part of that.
SAAD ALI: That is very exciting.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Yeah.
SAAD ALI: So let's
talk about KubeCon.
This is not your first KubeCon.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
No, no, it's not.
The last one in the US was in
my hometown of Austin, Texas.
So it's incredible to see
it just double in size
from December a year ago.
Copenhagen was incredible--
had a blast there.
Oh my god-- the
food in Copenhagen!
We ate our way through
the Michelin Guide
in Copenhagen. That
was a lot of fun.
But I also attended Berlin
a year and a half ago.
And boy, that was a small
conference, compared to this.
So it's grown up quite a bit.
SAAD ALI: What are
you looking forward
to this week at KubeCon?
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Yeah-- I
think really educating more
of the community--
what we're doing here--
but also learning from
the already advanced users
of Kubernetes,
hearing from them--
their use cases, if
they're a customer,
they're their pains, if they're
a developer trying to write
applications for Kubernetes.
As a product manager, it's
incredible opportunity
to get feedback from our
customers and the community.
SAAD ALI: That's awesome.
And finally, what's your
favorite KubeCon memory?
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
[LAUGHS] KubeCon memory.
I got a Kubernetes hoodie,
six months ago, I guess.
It was at the
Copenhagen KubeCon.
And I was wearing that hoodie
a week ago-- last week.
And I took my car
into the shop to have
some repairs done on it.
And in fact, the
mechanic that took my car
was wearing a GitHub hoodie.
And so I complimented
her on her hoodie.
And she told me, hey,
nice Kubernetes hoodie.
I like that.
And I just thought,
what a cool world
we live in where someone who's
evidently writing some code
and using GitHub on the side
is also working on my car
and in the same
field of endeavor we
are with Kubernetes.
And that's just--
SAAD ALI: That is wonderful.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: [INAUDIBLE].
SAAD ALI: That is the
beauty of open source.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Yeah.
SAAD ALI: All right, thank you
so much for your time, Dustin.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
Yeah, you bet, Saad.
Good to meet you.
SAAD ALI: Have a good one.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Yeah, yeah.
Good to see you.
SAAD ALI: Take care.
[MUSICAL JINGLE]